laughs
so basically this guy was streaming on
Twitch and he alt tabbed and somebody
looked at his tab The Syndicate took a
serious blow what time is it where I am
you didn't see it I didn't see it
because I'm not that quick so someone
paused it zoomed in
this right here
is what people zoomed in on okay so
people went to the lick found it
and it turned out he was
okay hold on what do you think of this
let's do trivia what do you think it is
it kids no
because this is if it's it's not illegal
huh it's not illegal if it gets weird
you would care if this was you okay this
is one of the problem I was careful it
was me if you were involved in the
situation if you would care you wanna
know why why
imagine if your best friend who's this
guy it's not the only fan of the wife of
a of one of his friends no okay it's
even worse in a way it's even worse this
guy so imagine your best friend
they found out that the tabs he had
opened he was looking at
were deep fakes of your girl
deep face on my girl
hey yo yeah
so he's the one of these fakes no he was
watching and consuming it
okay so my girlfriend is like another
YouTuber yeah yeah and they made deep
fakes to her and he was [__] he was
yeah
hey yo
hey yo yay hey hey weird what hey yo
what's the website
I know some of these people and
personally I'm not curious yeah but I
would imagine okay like jokes aside I
would imagine it'd be really [__]
upsetting for me if I was a woman online
just for creating stuff that one I can't
monetize that I didn't consent to you
and then they're reselling it and then
selling it if it if it was me and you
know feels like such a tremendous
violation of your boundaries that I
could understand a lot of people being
deeply upset by this or not being okay
with it or feeling really betrayed
especially if I found out one of the
guys I knew was doing this I would look
at him like oh you're helping to finance
this [__] that violates my boundaries so
deep fakes come into a really weird
territory where now people can do
anything there's deep fakes so probably
me online or if there isn't someone's
going to start but
it is a very upsetting thing yeah to see
your face plastered on someone's body
and it looks so real people can't even
tell the difference most of the time
like yeah I would feel very very upset
by it so I understand people's reaction
when they're mad yeah
this is but I'm still subscribed I got
it
to be honest you know I mean curiosity
as long as it's not me my [__] was a
joke calm down you know they're gonna
get you they're gonna get you for this
they can they can do whatever they want
but yeah and and but but then again
it's only weird because we're not
supposed to have access to that it's
like peep game everybody here has
fantasies about other people it happened
yeah yo people got fantasies about best
friends of girlfriends uh best friends
of boyfriends and [__] like that and at
the Deep face the Deep fake thing that
thing is just that but push I had access
of a to a part of your mind that I was
not supposed to that's what was weird
all right so he made an apology because
it involved a bunch of people that he
knows his friends like Pokemon and Maya
and different streams so he has deep
face of all those people there's a
website that has them he's subscribed
so let's hear why he did it and what
happened uh we called [__] buba spam
cringe we don't do that there I've never
made like a
weird I don't know seat sniffing show
I've never done anything like that I've
never done anything like that on a
stream and we don't tolerate any sex
behavior in the chat oh we ban it on
site I'm sorry this is just a big pet
peeve of mine there's nothing worse than
when the dude [__] up and then you
gotta do a press conference and his girl
or his wife got to sit behind him crying
too it's like he's the one who [__] up
why are you dragging her to make her
look stupid too you should be in front
of that camera by yourself don't do it
you [__] up don't She Gotta sit here
holding his head like I'm gonna stand by
him and we're gonna work through this
together lady he was looking at naked
bodies of his so-called friend's
girlfriends don't do it
you can stay whatever you want I just
think it's why when they've been
wearing this together don't do it
you [__] up by yourself you should own
up to it by yourself and then [__] at
2am
you know I've been watching so much I've
been reading so much [__] AI stuff
I'm reading all this [__] stuff about
Ai and and uh
defect music defect guard and everything
and I'm in these discords and I was I
feel so embarrassing of me
what that's that's his apology my bad is
your excuse that you were doing research
did you just take a [__] Meme and
turn it into real life
yeah oh no the reason why I got your
naked pictures on my phone is uh
research Academia is that your excuse
yeah research research because we say
that research oh yeah yeah who got a
tape yeah I'm gonna look at it for
research was that website what am I
grabbing who has to leave for a friend
yeah dry ashy elbows you know research
but I was on [__] PornHub dude I was
on [__] regular ass normal website
and there was an ad there's an ad on
every [__] video for this [__] so
I know other people must be clicking it
because it's on every [__] video for
[__] defecting and then I click it
and I'm getting this [__] rabbit hole
and at 2AM I [__]
I I don't know I got morbidly curious
and I click something and I and I it's
just [__] it's it's gross it's gross
and I'm sorry I really am I really
[__] it I just hate doing this on
stream man this is not what my stream's
about at all
I hate this drama stuff and I hate but I
just visited I hate drama I know
kept scrolling
scroll to see all their Negan bodies and
I was curious and then I just I came
[Laughter]
for people that are in my community
that were uh that were talking and they
they felt so let down and it made me
feel so fancy
so
as long as I live like as long as I know
I'll never do anything like this again
can someone make a deep think of this
guy doing the same apology but without
all these lame excuses I think that is
something I would pay for wow he's
getting [__] in the ass
by one of his viewers the one that
leaked the image
does he get invited to Thanksgiving
dinner
from who from the friend whose girl he
was looking at I don't know if it's you
know your whole that's weird though he's
your best friend though
it's weird
to me that thing is not really that much
of a thing I swear to God if it wasn't
me I don't think it would be that much
of a thing it's not like it you wouldn't
be upset by it I wouldn't be that upset
about it
um princess is a [__] no nothing
happened is him thinking [__]
I swear to God some a lot of you think
about your best friend's girls a lot of
you think about it so is it the same
thing as just thinking it's not just
thinking I don't think I would have an
issue if I find out a homie of mine
thought about my girl [__] because like
you can't stop invasive thoughts it is
what it is fine it's a different thing
when you start taking actions and you go
on our websites and you looking up
and you know and you're probably beating
your meat
about the fact that I've accepted that
when you're in public figure people can
do and say things about you that are not
true
I've been through it
and I ain't even that big and I think
that's just the normal
um
is the next step to that you know what I
mean but that's not just the public
that's your friend yeah that's what is
different that's your best friend yeah
you you got this homie over for 10 y'all
work together you guys have met
regularly
it doesn't it doesn't breach my
confidence it doesn't breach my
confidence are you going to invite him
to Thanksgiving hell no no no no
out here passing out stuffings while you
think about stuffing my girl no bro if I
think about stuffing your girl you're
never gonna yo listen if you thinking
you better not say no [__] like that if
you if you if you say listen you know
how disrespectful it would be if my
homie's like yo man I really want to
[__] you that's crazy
that's crazy you said it like that
it's lost yeah my man didn't even when
he started beating his beat I know he
want to do it now
what you talking that's great it's crazy
it's crazy if you listen we all have
crazy thought but a thought can go and
come and go it's fine it's not a thing
if you obsess over it might be a little
bit more weird and if you actually start
buying content or paying for stuff or
watching things online that's a bit
that's that's a bit too much
but yeah it still doesn't face me that
that them thoughts don't come and go it
really just come and come
all right let's just go
when it comes to anything like I we
don't do sexual jokes on here we don't I
can yo yo turn that [__] off turn it off
turn it off turn it off why because
sorry should have been sorry now you're
making all these [__] that ain't got
nothing to do with the fact I don't care
if you're vanilla chocolate blueberry a
chocolate chip I don't give a [__] get
to the point wrap it up Papa streamers
don't do that
okay like that nothing's gonna come out
of this and he's gonna say sorry he
[__] ruined it already he ruined it
it's ruined I want to know what
Spectacles on the back gotta say it's
yo listen
when have your face or your glasses I
call you spectacles you ain't got it
first time uh I don't know if you I'm
sorry I'll cut you off no it's just it's
deeply upsetting and extremely
embarrassing
but I do believe Brandon in saying this
is not a pattern of behavior
I bet you anything this probably made
her ass so insecure she probably got a
gym membership the next day found out
he's been jerking off the bodies of
homegirls of hers that's a wild thing
that's a [__] up thing to do to your
significant other than to put up in
front of the camera I think that shit's
way personally but hey everyone got
their own thing I don't know to me the
more you rambled on the more terrible
you see you know you could just say
listen curiosity got the best of me or I
listen I shouldn't have been but I was
just curious and I clicked on it like
and then just like that's my bad it's my
apologies I was very disrespectful keep
it pushing why do you think I just I'm
not I'm super vanilla like when I come I
just come on her back and and do you
want to say anything because I've been
cutting you off go tell them that I'm a
good man it was upsetting but I believe
him
[Applause]
shut the [__] up
this is cringe as hell bro
I was on these forums and there was like
deep fakes and Ai and I'm so curious and
so interested and then I found out my
best friend's girls butt naked in the
Deep fake so I'm like what does her
[__] look like for research purposes
and then I dug through the butthole and
I was like oh my God AI so amazing I
came
that's what it feels like it really
feels like I'm watching a child ramble
as they're trying to avoid
accountability it's just own it and keep
it pushing bro they try to what a
whooping yo the financial one yo so
those are my thoughts anything else you
want to say about deep fakes or anything
like that I think they need to pass laws
for deep fakes I think it should be I
think there will be that thing is so new
they will pass laws about deep fake
about uh AI chats and stuff like that
they will they should they will they
actually shouldn't be legal personally
that's what I think but yeah that's my
thoughts on anything else no all right
let's know what you guys think